One of the questions I get asked the
most is how in the world do I make my
RAG AI agents more accurate? And that is
what I want to cover with you in this
video. It's a very important question
because RAG is still the way to bring
external knowledge into our agents,
making them experts on our documents and
data, and it's still as relevant as
ever, even as LLMs are starting to
handle millions of tokens in a single
prompt. And generally, RAG is pretty
accurate. We ask our agent a question.
It searches our documents with rag and
that extra context that it fetches
usually helps to give us a better
answer. But why should we settle for
just pretty accurate? Some benchmarks
give basic rag 75% accuracy for pulling
relevant information to answer a user's
question while others site as low as 35
to 45%. If you want to build a real AI
solution that just won't cut it. And
today I'm going to show you a powerful
solution to this problem because it's
clear that you can't just go into a tool
like N8N and Langchain, build some
simple RAG AI agent and call it a day.
There is definitely a lot more than what
meets the eye that goes into building
rag solutions that actually work. And I
have been in the trenches the past weeks
diving deep into these strategies. And
as I've been drinking from the fire hose
of rag strategies, enhancing rag with
knowledge graphs has really stuck out to
me. Specifically using a powerful
open-source framework called light rag.
Light rag not only vectorizes your
documents like traditional rag. It also
builds up an allimportant graph that
connects topics, ideas, concepts
together from your documents to take the
contextual understanding of your AI
agent to the next dimension. And the
best part is it's pretty easy to get up
and running. So right now, allow me to
transform your rag strategy with a very
simple implementation of light rag
that's still pretty powerful and we'll
even compare it to a basic rag setup. So
we've got the code and we've got the
proof. Let's dive into it. So here is
the GitHub repository for light rag, the
star of our show today. And this
framework is legit. They even have a
research paper attached to this repo if
you really want to dive into all the
technicalities behind this framework and
they've got a nice diagram to go along
with this in the repo as well. I don't
want to focus on all of the
technicalities today because that gets
very deep but you can do that if you
want. Right now I just want to focus on
getting you started with light rag
because that in my mind is the most
practical but it is a very legit
framework. So, I wanted to call that out
quick so you know that there's a lot
going on behind the scenes. But working
with it is very, very easy. You just
install it as a pit package and then
their quick start gives us an overview
of what working with light rag looks
like. You can think of light rag as
being three distinct parts. First, we
set up an instance of our rag pipeline
like this. And this is where we define
things like the embedding model and the
large language model we want to use. And
you can customize all these things. And
then the second step is inserting data
into our knowledge graph and vector
database. We do both at the same time
with rag.insert and just passing in any
string that we want from any documents
that we have to parse. And this will
automatically chunk things and insert
things for us in an optimal way. So it
takes care of a lot of stuff for us. And
then the last part is running the actual
query. It's just rag.query with our
question and then our search mode. There
are a lot of different ways that we can
search our knowledge base with light
rag. We can do a naive search that's
just basic rag. We can do something like
a hybrid search. We can even do a mix
search which is really cool because this
will use both vector retrieval basic rag
and it'll search the knowledge graph. So
we literally lose out on nothing from
basic rag because we have that and more
with light rag. That's what makes it so
powerful. And there are a lot of options
for customization as well. Like I
mentioned you can change the LLM and
embedding model that you want to use.
You can use any OpenAI like API. If you
want to use something like Gemini or
Open Router, you can use Olama. They
have direct support for Olama for local
LLMs. And they have a lot of examples in
their example folder of using these
different options as well. And even
including other things like AWS Bedrock
or Azure OpenAI. So, they've got you
covered with examples for pretty much
anything to really help you get up and
running quickly. And then as far as
customizing the database that you use to
store all of your knowledge base, they
have a couple of options. You can use
Neo4j for the knowledge graph and then
also you can use Postgress. They added
this recently. You can use Postgress for
both the vector database and for the
graph DB with Apache age. And then one
thing that's outside of the scope of
this video that I definitely want to
cover later. What I've been playing with
is using Neo4j for just the knowledge
graph and then Postgress for just the
vector database and combining those two
together to really play into their
strengths. So I've been taking this
pretty far, but let's start with an
overview just getting you up and running
with a basic and powerful implementation
of light rag. And at the bottom of the
repo, they also show how light rag
compares to what they call a naive rag.
That's just basic or traditional rag.
And just look at the differences in
these percentages for how light rag
performs on all of these data sets. And
they give you instructions here for how
you can run all these tests yourself if
you want to replicate these results. And
so they put a lot of effort to really
give you the proof in the pudding here
with light rag and how good it is. And
so they compare it with a bunch of
different data sets. They even compare
it against graph rag. So this was a more
complex implementation of something
similar from Microsoft. Light rag is
simpler, faster, and it shows to be even
more powerful as well. So, it's really
just seems like the optimal knowledge
graph framework in my mind, which is why
I'm showing it to you today. So, first
thing I want to do a speedrun here,
showing you really quickly how to get up
and running with light rag with the
three components that we saw in the
GitHub repo. Then I'll dive into
building it into agents and we'll even
compare it against traditional rag to
see how well it does. And so first
things first, we need to create the
initialization of our rag instance just
following what we saw in the GitHub
repo. So we define our working directory
where we'll create the knowledge graph
locally and then choosing the embedding
model and large language model that we
want to use as well. We're just using
OpenAI for both of these. Then we
initialize our storage and the pipeline
so that we can insert into our knowledge
base. And that's what we do next. We
just use the asynchronous insert
function to insert all the information
that we want into our knowledge base.
And these could come from files if you
want as well. You can pull in files
locally or from the cloud, turn them
into strings, and then insert them in
exactly the same way. And light rag will
take care of all of the chunking and
optimize insertions for us. Once we have
everything in our knowledge base, then
we can run a query. So I can say rag dot
and then use the asynchronous query
function. I give it my question and then
I'm asking it to use the mixed mode for
search. So it'll use both the vector
database and the knowledge graph to find
my answer for me. And then finally I'll
just print out the result at the end.
And so now I can go to my terminal and I
can execute this Python script. And so
it's going to build up the rag pipeline,
insert everything into it, and then run
a query based on the question that I
defined at the bottom of the script.
It's just that easy to set up everything
for light rag. And obviously there's
more that goes into integrating with an
agent, but that's what I'm going to show
you in this video. And boom, there's our
answer. It says that Python is the
choice for us. And yes, that's
definitely right given what I inserted
into the knowledge base. So, this is
looking really good. And to expand on
this more, I've got something special to
show you. So, in order to show you how
to use LightRag and how powerful it is,
I created this solution, which is a
downloadable resource for you. So, you
can go to the GitHub link in the
description, take this right now, and
use it for yourself to get started very
quickly with Lightrag. And I'll show you
in this video how I set up everything.
But the structure of this project, we
have two rag agents. We have one
traditional rag implementation using
Chroma DB for a fast and local vector
database. And then I have a second AI
agent built with light rag. Both of
these are paid AI agents and I'm using
the same knowledge base for each so you
can test them side by side. specifically
the knowledge base that I built up for
each of these is I took the entire
Pantic AI documentation. So this is my
favorite Python agent framework right
now. I'm just using their documentation
as an example for this video. If you go
to
/lms.ext with their base URL
ai.pyantic.dev, you'll get this massive
text file. This is all the pideantic AI
documentation put together in a single
text file specifically for rag AI
agents. And so I took this and I
ingested this both into Chroma DB for
our traditional rag agent and then also
I have a knowledge graph just set up
locally for light rag. And so both of
these agents I have running as
streamllet user interfaces. And so this
looks the exact same but each of these
is chatting with one of the AI agents
specifically. And so I can ask the same
question to both and we can see what
kind of results we get because under the
hood things are looking a lot different
in the way that the agent is actually
accessing the knowledge base. Now one of
the main limitations of light rag and
really rag as a whole is that it can be
quite difficult to work with real time
data because every time you want to
update your knowledge base you have to
reinsert documents into your vector
database and recomputee your knowledge
graph. It is not a fast process. So, how
in the world are you supposed to build
AI agents that integrate with complex
and constantly evolving data like user
interactions and time-sensitive metrics?
The solution to this is a powerful
open-source platform for building real
time knowledge graphs called Graffiti.
Graffiti is sponsoring this segment, but
I specifically waited to put them in
this video because it is the perfect
solution for you when you need something
like light rag, but for constantly
changing data, and it powers the core of
Zep's memory layer. So, it really is the
real deal. So, here's the GitHub
repository for graffiti. And because
it's open source, you can get started
with it right now completely for free to
build powerful rag agents in Python. And
what really makes graffiti stand out is
the way that it can maintain constantly
evolving relationships in a knowledge
graph and it can maintain historical
context so your AI agent can know how
these relationships have changed over
time. It is very unique. I will have a
link to graffiti in the description. If
you're looking to build AI agents that
work with constantly changing
information, then graffiti is the
solution for you and I'd highly
recommend checking them out. So to start
out with a nice and simple test, I just
want to have both agents use the Pyantic
AI documentation to create me a full AI
agent implementation for an agent that
can search the web with Brave. It's just
a nice and simple test that I like to
run a lot when I'm trying to have an AI
coding assistant build an AI agent for
me. Like I do this with Archon, my AI
agent builder as well. And so I'll take
this request, I'll send it into the
light rag agent and then go over to the
streamllet UI and send the exact same
request into the Chromma DB agent. And
because Chromb only has to search the
vector database and not the knowledge
graph as well, it is going to give us a
faster response. But yeah, I just saw
that flash here. Take a look at this.
For some reason, it decided to use the
duckgo search tool provided by Pinantic
AI instead of doing anything with Brave.
And this is a classic hallucination
where the wrong context is pulled from
the documentation and that causes it to
think that it has to use something
completely different to implement the
agent. So it's using a totally different
search tool instead of brave probably
because of what was returned from rag
and I don't know that absolutely for
sure but I have seen these kind of
hallucinations a lot with traditional
rag and so now let's go over and see
what was produced for light rag. So let
me scroll up here to see the top of the
results. Yeah, this is looking a lot
better. I mean, you don't have to
understand Pantic AI code. This is just
an example that I'm using, but I'm very
familiar with the framework. And this
looks like clean Pantic AI code, and it
is using Brave for the web search tool.
So, this is looking a lot better. And it
doesn't fully implement the Brave
search, which makes sense because the
agent only has the Pyantic AI docs, not
the Brave doc. So, it's just simulating
this request, which I respect that. and
it's just having a placeholder for the
model here. So, it's not perfect code.
Like, I couldn't just run this as is,
but it definitely seems like it has a
better context around what I'm trying to
build and tying that specifically to the
documentation in Pantic AI for that. So,
this is looking good. I'd say that light
rag wins. And you'll see that in
general, light rag will just almost
always outperform traditional rag,
especially as your knowledge base grows
exponentially. So if you have thousands
or hundreds of thousands of documents,
that's when normal rag really starts to
fall apart, but light rag is going to
keep up because we have so much more
contextual understanding of our
knowledge because we have the knowledge
graph as well. So maybe I'll do some
more testing later, but right now I want
to show you exactly how I built this
light rag agent so you can build them
for yourself. All right, so lastly back
to our GitHub repo because we now know
how light rag works, why it's so
powerful, and we tested it against
traditional rag. And so now I want to
show you how you can build your own
light rag agent just based on all the
code that I have here as a free resource
for you. So you can take a look at this
read me at the root of the repo and you
can go through these instructions to set
up everything yourself or you can just
take this code and bring it into your
own project. I don't mind. I just want
you to use this however you wish. I just
want to provide as much value as I can
to you, but I want to really quickly
cover a few of the important files for
setting up our light rag agent. So,
first we have this one right here. This
is our Python script that is responsible
for pulling the Pyantic AI documentation
and building up our light rag knowledge
base. And all that's going to be stored
locally in this pyantic docs folder. So
all these JSON files represent our
vector database and knowledge graph. And
later I might include Neo4j or Postgress
for external storage but right now I'm
just keeping it very simple with a local
knowledge graph. And so within this
script first we're going to import all
of our libraries and load our
environment variables. And then in the
main function there are just two things
that I need to do. First I have to
initialize the rag pipeline like we saw
in the quick start example in the light
rag repo. And then I want to fetch all
the podantic AI documentation and just
insert that into our knowledge base.
That is all that this script has to do.
It's pretty simple. And so we'll just
implement these two functions right now.
Starting with the function to initialize
our rag pipeline. And so I just followed
the documentation from light rag for
this. It's all pretty boilerplate stuff.
It's nice and simple. We first create
our rag instance just based on our
working directory that we'll define in a
second. And then we select our embedding
model and large language model. So I'm
just using OpenAI for both specifically
GPT4 mini for my large language model.
That's what I'm using for the Chromabb
agent as well. And then I just have to
initialize the stoages and the pipeline
status. And now I can return this rag
instance so that we can then use it to
insert all of the records. And so that's
it for initializing things. Now we can
build up the function to fetch the
podantic AI documentation. So first I
added in this piece to define the
working directory. So that's important
because that tells the script that you
need to create the knowledge graph
within this folder right here like we
can see because I already ran this
script. So we've got that defined and we
create that folder if it doesn't exist.
And then I select the URL for the Pantic
AI documentation. And that's the beauty
of having the LLM's.ext is this entire
script only has to pull from one URL to
get all of the documentation for rag.
It's very very neat. And so within my
function to fetch the padantic AI docs,
all I need to do is use the HTTP client
to fetch this single URL and then return
the text for it and then also just
handle any other errors as well. And
that's it. So now this call gives me all
of the Pantic AI documentation as a
single string that I can then insert
into my knowledge base because lightrag
takes care of the chunking and inserting
and everything. And so within just 53
lines of code, we now have this script
that we can run whenever we want to
update our knowledge base with the
latest Pantic AI docs. And then keep in
mind once you run this script to build
up your knowledge base, it's going to
take a while because it has to create
the vector database and knowledge graph
and compute that all. And so to create
all these files, you'll have to probably
wait at least 20 minutes because it is
ingesting the entire Pyantic AI
documentation. But you just run this
once and then you don't ever have to run
it again unless you want to update your
knowledge base. And so you just deal
with that long run the first time and
then when we run our agent going
forward, it's going to be very fast
spinning up that instance of our rag
knowledge base. And so now over to our
agent, I'm going to import all the
libraries that we need and then define
the same working directory so that we're
referencing the knowledge base that we
created with the other script. And then
I want to throw an error if we don't
have our OpenAI API key set. Obviously,
we need that for our agent. And then I'm
going to initialize our rag in the same
way that I did in the other script. So
defining the working directory, our
embedding model, and our large language
model. And then I'll initialize the
stoages. And I don't have to initialize
the pipeline status this time because we
only are doing that here since we're
inserting into the vector database. So
now I can just return rag. And then
boom, we have a rag instance that we can
then inject into our agent so it can
perform rag. And so we'll define the
dependencies for our agent. So this is
the light rag instance that we're going
to inject into our agent just using
classic pantic AI dependencies. And then
we'll define the agent itself, which
this should look very familiar to you
with the agent that we just created in
Streamlib. We're using GPT4 mini just
like we're using with light rag. We set
up our dependencies and then we give it
a nice system prompt as well. And then
for the single tool that we're giving to
our agent to keep things nice and
simple, we're giving it the ability to
based on a search query that the agent
decides itself, it will call this
retrieve tool to search the knowledge
base. And so we give it a nice dock
string. This is given as a part of the
prompt to the LLM to tell it when and
how to use this retrieve function. And
it's very simple, just three lines of
code. We take our light rag instance
that we're putting into our agent. We're
calling the asynchronous query function,
giving it the search query, and then
also we're using the mix search mode. So
it'll search both with vector retrieval
and it'll search the knowledge graph. So
we got the best of both worlds here. And
then I also have this main function here
if you want to run the agent as a
standalone script. I'm not going to
cover this though because the more
important part is this streamllet
application that I created. So we can
interact with it with a UI in the
browser. And Streamllet is not the focus
of this video. So I'm not going to cover
this in detail, but you can take a look
at this if you want to see how we set up
light rag as a dependency. We inject
that into our agent when we execute it
right here. And so this is where we call
our agent for each message that we send
into the interface and we're streaming
that response out with the generator
here so that we can get the result in
typewriter style out in the UI like we
saw earlier. So that is our full light
rag agent. And of course, let me know in
the comments if you have any questions
on this, if you want me to expand it in
certain ways, making it more robust,
adding in external storage. I definitely
want to cover some more things in future
videos for light rag cuz I definitely
think that it is a big deal. And then
for our basic rag implementation, I
don't even really have to cover it
because it's mostly the same. The one
thing that's really cool to see though,
take a look at how long our script is to
ingest the Pantic AI documentation
compared to the one for light rag
because we have to do all the chunking
and inserting ourself. It's a lot more
complex. And so this script
is 177 lines of code. But if we go to
the same script for light rag, it's only
53. So you might have a little bit more
control if you're doing all of the
chunking and inserting yourself. So
there could be advantages to doing that
all yourself with a vector database like
chromadabb. But it is certainly nice
that light rag is taking care of so much
for us and it it's also optimizing so
much behind the scenes that I don't
really care that it's a definitely
larger level of abstraction compared to
chromabb. Usually I'm not the biggest
fan of abstraction but because of how
technically developed light rag is it's
not a big deal to me. I I respect it.
And so yeah, that's inserting the Pantic
AI docs for Chroma DB. And then setting
up the agent is almost exactly the same
where we have our dependencies with
everything that we need for Chroma. And
then we have our single retrieve tool
that will just use Chromma DB instead of
light rag. And then the Streamlit app is
the most similar out of everything
because the UI is set up in exactly the
same way. Even the way that we interact
with the agent is set up in the same
way. Nice and simple. One last final
note for you is I encourage you to play
around with these different solutions.
So download this repo, run it all
yourself, just hook in your OpenAI API
key. That's the only thing you need and
then you can try out these different
setups with the exact same questions cuz
it's all using the Pantic AI
documentation under the hood. So you can
play around with a bunch of different
questions, see if you get different
results with basic rag compared to light
rag. And I will say for most of the
requests, you will get pretty similar
results, especially because it is a
smaller knowledge base. Light rag will
mostly excel once you have thousands or
hundreds of thousands of documents. But
it's still fun to play around with these
different things and see the kind of
responses that you get. And you can play
around with different modes of search
for light rag as well and do a lot of
optimization with that. So, I'd be super
curious to hear if you try this out
yourself, especially if you have a
larger knowledge base, if you get
different results between these
different solutions. So, I hope that
this video has helped you level up your
rag agents with light rag and knowledge
graphs. And this isn't the only way to
make rag more accurate, even though it
is a gamecher. You also have agentic
rag, query expansion, reranking. There's
so many strategies that I want to keep
diving into on my channel. So, if you
appreciated this video and you're
looking forward to more things AI agents
and rag strategies, I would really
appreciate a like and a subscribe. And
with that, I will see you in the next